cuáles figuras son simétricas para poder
responder esto necesitamos saber qué
significa que una figura sea simétrica
una figura es simétrica si tiene al
menos un eje de simetría pero entonces
te preguntarás bueno qué es un eje de
simetría es un eje de simetría
es una línea recta que atraviesa una
figura tal que si doblamos la imagen de
la figura ambas mitades de la figura
quedan perfectamente emparejadas
entonces bueno para entender esto veamos
un ejemplo muy bien entonces tomamos un
círculo ahora vamos a trazar una línea
recta que lo atraviese esta línea recta
es un eje de simetría si podemos tomar
un lado de la figura doblarlo en el otro
lado y lograr que quede perfectamente
emparejado entonces tenemos aquí un lado
de la figura vamos a tomarle lado que
sea no importa cual así que bueno voy a
tomar este lado de arriba y si los doblo
si doblo este lado de arriba hacia abajo
quedará perfectamente emparejado con el
lado de abajo bueno si yo doblo este
lado de arriba hacia abajo probablemente
se va a mirar algo así
y ahora eso está perfectamente
emparejado no verdad no en
definitivamente no lo está por lo tanto
este no es un eje de simetría
ahora voy a trazar otra línea recta y
veamos si está si es un eje de simetría
para el círculo voy a trazar esta línea
recta haciendo el mayor esfuerzo por
hacer que pase exactamente por el centro
del círculo que quede bien trazada y que
sea una línea recta muy bien entonces
tenemos esta línea recta que pasa por el
centro
ahora vamos a doblar un lado del círculo
en el otro lado no importa cual lado yo
tomé así que voy a tomar el lado
izquierdo del círculo supongamos que
dobló el lado izquierdo del círculo en
el lado derecho del círculo quedarán
perfectamente emparejados en los lados
del círculo si yo hago ese doblez
si la línea recta que yo dibujé si pasa
por el centro del círculo entonces si
estos dos lados si quedarán
perfectamente emparejados lo cual quiere
decir que esta línea recta si es un eje
de simetría para el círculo y dado que
nos es posible trazar este eje de
simetría en el círculo podemos entonces
decir que el círculo es una figura
simétrica baja una figura es simétrica
si tiene al menos un eje de simetría un
círculo tiene muchísimos ejes de
simetría
pero bueno aquí tienes un eje de
simetría y como basta tener un solo eje
de simetría para que una figura sea
simétrica con este único eje de simetría
basta ya tenemos una figura simétrica el
círculo es una figura simétrica así que
bueno ya entendimos lo que es un eje de
simetría y lo que es que una figura sea
simétrica entonces bueno vamos a
analizar las figuras y veamos cuáles son
simétricas entonces bueno vamos a
iniciar con la primera figura aquí
tenemos un triángulo si trazamos una
línea recta vertical intentando pasar
justo por la
del triangulo algo asi luego tomamos
este lado y lo doblamos hacia el otro
lado estas dos líneas van a quedar
emparejadas perfectamente pero esta otra
línea quedará algo asi por lo que no
quedará perfectamente emparejada por lo
que esta línea recta no es un eje de
simetría
también puedes notar que cualquier otra
línea recta vertical que tracemos
tampoco será un eje de simetría no
importa donde yo la ponga así que bueno
vamos a intentar ahora con una línea
recta horizontal a ver si ese funciona a
ver si esta resulta ser un eje de
simetría para el triángulo en algún
lugar será posible trazar una línea
recta horizontal que sea un eje de
simetría puedes notar que no que pasara
exactamente lo mismo que con la línea
recta vertical los lados que quedan
divididos por la recta no quedarán
perfectamente emparejados a la hora de
doblar el uno en el otro
-ha como como último intento vamos a ver
si si funciona trazar una línea recta
diagonal algo así doblamos la parte de
abajo hacia arriba y esta línea quedará
sobre esta línea y este lado terminará
mirándose algo así entonces bueno casi
casi quedó emparejado pero observa que
nos falta
aparte no encaja perfectamente para que
esta línea recta sea un eje de simetría
necesitamos que los dados queden
perfectamente emparejados y bueno en
esta primera figura no logramos dibujar
una línea recta horizontal o vertical o
diagonal que fuera un eje de simetría
así que esta figura como no tiene un eje
de simetría no es una figura simétrica
ahora vamos a analizar la segunda figura
que es un rectángulo
veamos si esta figura es simétrica así
que voy a trazar una línea recta
horizontal si esta línea recta pasa
justo por enmedio del rectángulo
entonces este lado quedará emparejado
con este lado perfectamente este lado de
arriba quedará emparejado con este lado
de abajo y estos lados al doblar el uno
en el otro también deberán quedar
emparejados perfectamente si es que
dibuje la línea recta justo por el medio
por lo tanto el rectángulo tiene un eje
de simetría y por lo tanto el rectángulo
es una figura simétrica
el rectángulo tiene más de un eje de
simetría esta línea recta que pasa por
enmedio también es un eje de simetría
pero sabemos que basta encontrar un solo
eje de simetría en una figura para saber
si una figura es simétrica ahora
finalmente vamos a analizar al pentágono
entonces bueno vamos a iniciar trazando
una línea recta que pase por el medio
siempre trazar una línea recta por el
medio es una buena idea para saber si
este es un eje de simetría
entonces bueno supongamos que esta línea
recta pasa justo por el centro de este
pentágono si doblamos este lado de la
figura en el otro este lado del
pentágono debe quedar bien emparejado
con este lado del pentágono este lado y
este quedarán emparejados y estos dos
lados también quedarán emparejados
perfectamente por lo que el pentágono si
tiene un eje de simetría y por lo tanto
es simétrico y bueno así así como sucede
con el rectángulo el pentágono también
tiene más ejes de simetría aquí está
otro eje de simetría aquí está otro eje
de simetría aquí está otro eje de
simetría así que bueno atrás c123 cuatro
ejes de simetría
pero bueno con que tenga un solo eje de
simetría con eso basta para saber que
una figura es simétrica
así que bueno para finalizar de las
figuras que se nos dieron el rectángulo
y el pentágono son figuras simétricas